yeah
this is Lagos
the most populated city in Africa
it's the financial capital of Nigeria
the continent's largest economy
more than 15 million people live here
that's twice the size of the next
biggest African Mega City
coastal town is now a heaving Metropolis
attracting economic migrants from all
over West Africa but as the City's
population keeps growing you can really
feel the infrastructure Buckle under the
pressure
earlier this year the state expanded its
population control policy
granting access to free contraceptives
but first they need to be convinced
at least 95 million people here live
below the poverty line and as families
keep growing there are more mouths to be
fed so how are you able to provide for
your children for your five children
organizations are working with Community
leaders to bridge the gap in Awareness
an education that comes second to
tradition
but can the women here make the decision
themselves about what they want to do
around having children oh it is not
possible because when we came there they
said they cannot do anything without
their husbands okay why do people want
to keep having more children
it's culture
tradition
it goes a long way to to its place a
long path
just on the other side of the Lagos
Lagoon is makoko
been living here in Moco for over a
hundred years but as climate change
intensifies and the world's population
surges this growing Community is one of
the most at risk there's just not enough
space
taiwo is the son of mokoko's Chief and
runs a school and orphanage here
[Music]
we have a 200 000 people living on water
and we have 200 000 people living on
land and right now the kids the children
are more than the adults
they don't even want to have a child
anymore
Lagos is just one of many cities facing
extreme population pressure inhabitable
land is becoming harder and harder to
find with 8 billion people now living on
Earth the most vulnerable will be the
most overwhelmed
Sky News Lagos